unsere bundeskanzlerin ist eine frau die
klimadebatte wird von kreta thunberg
bestimmt und selbst in einer
männerdomäne wie das zeigen frauen
mittlerweile auch dass sie siegen können
frauen werden immer mächtiger und
trotzdem sind wir bei der
gleichberechtigung in deutschland noch
nicht am ziel das zeigt auch ganz
aktuell eine studie des
weltwirtschaftsforums zum beispiel bei
gehältern oder führungspositionen
was also muss in diesem neuen jahrzehnt
passieren
wir sprechen gleich mit einer frau die
sagt zitat die gläserne decke würden
sich die frauen selbst schafften von
frauen förderprogramm hält die
kommunikationsberaterin sellin willers
nichts die sagt wir frauen müssen uns
einfach nehmen was uns zusteht
schönheitskönigin moderatorin
kommunikationsberaterin céline flores
willers fühlt sich auf ihn wohl 2018
trat sie für deutschland zur wahl der
miss universe an den titel gewannen die
stuttgarterin zwar nicht dafür aber
sicherlich an reichweite zum zweiten mal
in folge gehört sie zu den top influence
an auf linkedin
hier spricht die über themen wie flug
taxis home office und ihre eltern
außerhalb des internets bereit die
26-jährige unternehmen wie die von
linkedin profitieren können nicht
profitieren will céline flores willers
von einer frauenquote dass er dir
schlecht
ihre these was frauen in deutschland
meiner meinung nach fehlt ist der glaube
an das eigene können unternehmen haben
so viele frauen förderprogramme dass mir
die jungs leid tun
[Musik]
und live zugeschaltet in stuttgart ist
merz elin flores willers guten abend
favelas hallo
wenn ich jetzt mal dieses zitat ganz am
ende auf greife sind frauen ihrer
meinung nach selbst daran schuld wenn
sie kann schafft posten bekommen
das heißt selbst daran schuld ich glaube
in deutschland ist es mittlerweile so
dass frauen genauso wie männer
gleichberechtigt die chance auf einen
solchen chefposten haben und dass viele
frauen oder das ja immer noch weniger
frauen als männer in chefposten sind
liegt ja meine meinung daran dass auch
einfach nicht so viele frauen das
unbedingt wollen und vielleicht noch
nicht so viel stress und arbeit die
damit verbunden ist in kauf nehmen um in
solche positionen zu gelangen
die wiederum die das wollen wir schaffen
das auch und davon bin ich überzeugt
dass wir frauen das können und schaffen
wenn wir das denn wollen wenn man wenn
ich das 2 dafür darf sie sagen außerdem
man muss mutig sein und selbstbewusst
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
absolut ja natürlich also das gehört auf
jeden fall dazu ich meine da im
zweifelsfall entscheidet man über top
wirtschaftskonzerne man über scheide
entscheidet über politisch wichtige
situation für ein land wie deutschland
und natürlich erfordert das blut für
männer als auch für frauen und den
müssen frauen eben genauso aufbringen
wie männer wenn sie eine solche position
inne haben möchten
sie sind gegen gezielte frauenförderung
warum weil ich der meinung sind dass
frauen das nicht brauchen weil ich eben
der meinung bin dass wenn frauen das
unbedingt wollen dann bekommen sie das
auch weil die chancen dafür sind gegeben
und sind eben weitgehend oder sind
gleich in deutschland zumindest also
spreche immer von deutschland und
deswegen halte ich davon nichts weil die
letzten also lasst uns mal von einer
frauenquote ausgehen wenn dann frauen in
so eine position kommen die es wirklich
drauf haben und dies wirklich verdient
haben weil die das talent dazu haben und
die skills dafür haben dann kann immer
im endeffekt gesagt wenn ja ja aber die
wurde da er nur hingesetzt wegen der
frauenquote und ich glaube das will
keine frau die karriere machen möchte
da würden jetzt wahrscheinlich viele
sagen die für eine quote sind wenn sie
ihren job gut macht dann werden diese
stimme aber wahrscheinlich auch schnell
verstummen
ich glaube trotzdem dass wir das einfach
nicht nötig haben und das glaubt auch
nicht nur ich sondern dadurch dass ich
mich ja eben viel in der
jaja startup szene aber auch mit großen
corporates und wirtschaftskonzerne
auseinandersetze auf vielen bühnen auch
unterwegs bin wo ich mit vielen top
managerinnen und managern spreche da
bekomme ich auch auf das feedback gerade
von diesen top managerin die mir sagen
ja nicht stimmen die absolut zu ich habe
den artikel gelesen ich sehe das ganz
genauso und erstaunlicherweise ist es
dann aber so dass ich dann natürlich
total frei sagt ach echt cool
würdest du mir ganz kurzen statement on
camera dafür geben für meinen linkedin
channel und dann heißt es tatsächlich
aber nee nee nee das kann ich nicht
machen für so für so was werde ich auf
jeden fall dann zerrissen oder das geht
nicht du will sich unser unternehmen
nicht positionieren und das ist ja auch
das was ich ein bisschen kritisiere an
dieser ganzen female im parlament
bewegungen dass sie so weit getrieben
hat was eigentlich grundsätzlich erstmal
eine gute bewegung warme und was uns ja
überhaupt erst hierhin gebracht haben
dass wir so gleichberechtigt sind
aber jetzt an dem punkt ist wo das eben
überschwappt und er ist seit fast
gefährlich wird oder im toxisch habe ich
in meinem artikel genannt weil es eben
keine anderen meinungen er zuletzt um
dass sich leute nicht mehr trauen zu dem
thema ihre meinung kundzutun im internet
oder aber auch eben vor der kamera wie
ich jetzt zeigen wir ganz deutlich dass
es irgendwie ja einen schritt zu weit
gegangen ist das ganze im parlament gibt
es ja auch frauen denen das nicht so in
die wiege gelegt ist so selbstbewusst zu
und mutig zu sein die das eben einfach
nicht sofort mitbringen wie sollen die
das denn lernen wenn es nun keine
weiblichen vorbilder gibt und noch ist
es ja so noch gibt es nicht so viele
weibliche vorbilder in den chefetagen
also es gibt die definitiv und ich frage
mich grundsätzlich warum brauchen wir
dann weibliche vorbilder also mein ich
habe kein weibliches vorbild ich
orientiere mich an leuten deren
positionen oder deren meinungen deren
skills ich besonders toll finde das kann
barack obama sein es kann nass sein die
sich für innovation einsetzen die
irgendwie eine ganze industrie
diskutieren und warum kann nicht mein
vorbild dienen meist seien das verstehe
ich schon mal grundsätzlich einfach
nicht ehrlich gesagt also vorbilder
haben wir genug ob das barak ist oder
eine ja auch eine frau wie sheryl
sandberg ceo von facebook also da haben
wir ganz viele
fakt ist allerdings wir sind bei der
gleichberechtigung ja noch nicht ganz am
ziel angelangt und wir schauen uns jetzt
mal den aktuellen stand der dinge an
europa 2009 10
ursula von der leyen wird präsidentin
der europäischen kommission genfer
morgen erste frau an der spitze eines
dax konzerns und christine lagarde
übernimmt den vorsitz der europäischen
zentralbank mächtige posten erstmals
besetzt von frauen wie weit sind wir
2009 10 also gekommen beim thema
gleichberechtigung forscher ist es so
dass jeden tag ein partner oder
ex-partner versucht eine frau zu
ermorden also jeden tag versucht auf ihn
zieht jeden dritten tag wird eine frau
ermordet schwangerschaftsabbruch ist
illegal in deutschland bis auf ausnahmen
wir haben nicht mal tritt landfrauen im
bundestag
die probleme sind riesig der global
gender pay gap report des
weltwirtschaftsforums vergleicht
gleichberechtigung anhand von faktoren
wie beispielsweise bildung gehälter und
führungspositionen
aktuelle ergebnisse zeigen deutschland
liegt insgesamt auf platz zehn hinter
ländern wie ruanda oder spanien
immerhin im vergleich zum ersten ranking
2006 sind wir fünf plätze vorgerückt an
der spitze zum elften mal in folge
island dicht gefolgt von norwegen
finnland und schweden
was machen andere allen voran nordische
länder also besser
schweden hat seit den 70er jahren
bestimmte änderungen rechtliche
änderungen eingeführt wie abschaffung
von ehegatten splitting eine konsequente
bekämpfung von männlicher gewalt gegen
frauen und viele andere themen so dass
nord nordische länder die
skandinavischen länder irgendwie
schweden viel weiter vorne sondern als
deutschland muss ich habe eben nur wenn
man das problem also strukturelles
anzieht und nicht wie einige menschen
als eine individualisierte sache was die
zahlen des weltwirtschaftsforums noch
ergeben von gleichstellung sind wir in
vielen bereichen noch weit entfernt
knapp 100 jahre dauert es demnach bis
frauen und männer auf politischer ebene
gleichberechtigt repräsentiert werden
bis zur gleichen bezahlung noch achtung
257 jahre
was kann deutschland schon jetzt tun um
die lücke zwischen den geschlechtern zu
schließen
[Musik]
paragrafen 218 und 219 allem im
strafgesetzbuch zu
schwangerschaftsabbruch ein bisschen
abgeschafft werden so dass alle menschen
und eben auch frauen völlige freiheit
über den eigenen körper bekommen
die ökonomische um gleichberechtigung
die wir gerade in den zahlen vom
weltwirtschaftsforum so deutlich gesehen
haben kann angegangen werden indem man
beispielsweise das ehegattensplitting
abgeschafft oder altersarmut vor allem
bei frauen konsequent angeht europa 2020
ein neues jahrzehnt in dem vielleicht
nicht nur vereinzelt frauen
machtpositionen bekommen sondern
gleichberechtigung auch strukturell mehr
in den fokus gerückt wird
wir hören frau dunst hat hier durchaus
eine andere haltung als sie frau villas
aber bleiben wir jetzt doch mal bei
diesen gesellschaftlichen strukturen die
auch im beitrag angesprochen worden sind
wenn man jetzt zum beispiel für sein
kind keinen betreuungsplatz findet wenn
man auf alte rollenbilder stößt oder zum
beispiel auf mächtige männer netzwerke
die sich eben vor allem gegenseitig
befördern sind das dann keine
hindernisse
also zu dem thema mutter sein und auch
dieses schwangerschaft abrufe von grade
gesprochen werden da wenn ich ganz
ehrlich bin habe ich keine forschung in
dem gebiet kenne ich mich zu schlecht
aus in meinem artikel und die position
die ich vertrete bezieht sich eben immer
auf frauen in deutschland und auch
frauen die sich in einer ähnlichen
situation befinden ähnlich alt sind wie
ich also ungebunden sind und bei denen
bin ich eben der meinung dass sie
definitiv chancen gleich männern
gegenüber stehen und ich für mich und
auch aus meinem freundeskreis habt und
das noch nicht erfahren dass einfach
eine frau in meinem alter gescheitert
ist weil ja männerdominanz so groß war
die sie nicht gefördert haben oder nicht
durchgelassen haben sondern dass wir
entschieden wird ist letztendlich auf
basis der leistung einer person und die
muss eben entsprechend gut sein für
bestimmte posten und das kann man als
auch eine frau erreichen und ich sehe
diese hindernisse in dem umfeld in dem
ich mich bewege und arbeite sehe ich den
einfach nicht da sind männer als auch
frauen darüber aufgeklärt und nehmen das
als selbstverständlich hin oder die
meisten oder das nicht als
selbstverständlich hin dass frauen und
männer gleichberechtigt sind also ich
kenne keinen mann der da noch
widerspricht in
es ist aber nun so dass viele sich dann
doch irgendwann eine familie wünschen
und irgendwie ändert sich dann ja
einiges bei den männern bleibt das recht
ähnlich obwohl sie kinder haben aber bei
den frauen kann es dann schon schwierig
werden oder sehen sie das anders ich bin
leider noch nicht oder noch nicht
einfach in der situation ein kind zu
bekommen und kann mich da und deswegen
schwer hinein versetzen ich kenne auf
dem gebiet nicht genau die zahlen und
deswegen fällt es mir schwer eine
aussage zu treffen ich kann einfach nur
von dem sprechen wie ja wie ich jetzt
lebe und in meiner altersklasse und da
kann ich das definitiv sagen wie das ist
wenn man kinder hat da möchte ich keine
behauptung aufstellen weil ich die
einfach weil ich die erfahrung sei aber
noch nicht gemacht habe bin ich mal
gespannt wie das dann ist ja okay also
weshalb mir jetzt mal fest es geht hier
in ihrer haltung vor allem um junge
jüngere menschen oder auf jeden fall
menschen die keine kinder haben
ich guck mal kurz in die kommentare und
hier gibt es auf jeden fall sehr viel
zuspruch
robert schreibt zum beispiel bei
facebook mehr frauen in
führungspositionen wäre sehr gut aber
ohne quote schreibt er
hier schreibt noch jemand er findet es
gut dass hiermit auch eine andere
position hat aber es kommt eben auch die
frage dann doch danach nach bessere
akzeptanz zum beispiel von eltern zeiten
auch für männer und tatsächlich ist das
ja auch so ein punkt wenn jetzt zum
beispiel feministinnen für ministerin
eine quote fordern das hatten sie auch
vorhin angesprochen dass das auch
zumindest übergangsweise vielleicht auch
nur foto fordern
da kann das ja auch durchaus in
chefetagen strukturen ändern zum
beispiel die vereinbarkeit von familie
und beruf vereinfachen das ist ja der
gedanke unter anderem auch wenn frauen
jetzt dort mehr werden
doch dann am ende eigentlich alle was
von sowohl frauen als auch männer oder
ja also können sie tanzen und die frage
wird noch mal wiederholt also wenn wir
eine quote ein ist ja bei manchen
tatsächlich der gedanke dass strukturen
sich ändern
in ihrem artikel zum beispiel haben sie
auch geschrieben man müsste mehr power
geben man müsste noch mehr stress
aushalten haben wäre ebenso man müsste
einsatzbereit sein als frau jetzt kann
man das gleich manchmal nicht wenn man
eben kinder zu hause hat und das
betrifft männer ja genauso wie frauen am
ende und die idee dass man
wer eben wenn man mehr frauen in den
chefetagen hat dann auch die strukturen
sich dort ändern vereinbarkeit von
familie und beruf zum beispiel einfach
wäre
das werden ja auch wer auf die männer
gut oder klar ich meine wir brauchen auf
jeden fall brauchen wir diese angebote
wir brauchen unterstützung für männer
als auch frauen also grundsätzlich
einfach für junge familien so dass
frauen als auch männer ihre jobs weiter
ausüben kann auf jeden fall das brauchen
wir das kommt allen zugute
die karriere machen wollen und trotzdem
der familie haben wollen definitiv da
würde ich mich niemals gegen äußern auf
jeden fall brauchen wir da an bord also
wären sie durchaus auch für eine quote
einfach übergangsweise um das zum bei
hinzubekommen war warum nicht nein weil
ich einfach glaube dass trotzdem eine
quote rückschrittlich ist weil das
einfach zeigt das wie eine quote
brauchen um dahin zu kommen und die
brauchen wir nicht also ich glaube das
ist einfach grundsätzlich das falsche
signal eine quote einzuführen ich glaube
wir können oder frauen können in diese
position gelangen ohne eine quote und
wir können trotzdem ja was dafür tun das
ist diese unterstützung gibt wenn man
beispielsweise ein kind hat also das
eine steht ja nicht im widerspruch zu
dem andern warum muss man eine quote
haben damit wir endlich unterstützung
bekommt für ich weiß nicht kinder
kita-plätze ich kenne mich auf dem
gebiet absolut nicht aus da bin ich noch
weit vom wind fährt aber ich finde das
steht absolut nicht im widerspruch
zueinander und ich brauchen trotzdem
keine quote und wenn sie jetzt davon
sprechen dass sie viele male im
parlament sondern sie ist ja nervt was
meinen sie denn dann ganz genau also die
quote das habe ich jetzt schon mal
verstanden aber was dennoch also mich
stört grundsätzlich dass viel mehr in
peine bewegung geworden ist sie einfach
keine andere meinungen mehr zulässt und
ich glaube grundsätzlich alle extrem ob
das auch fluten politischer ebene ist
oder ja auch in anderen bereichen sind
einfach nicht gut weil das eben extreme
sind und so ist es eben mit dem filmen
im parlament auch das sind einfache
bewegung geworden die oftmals keine
andere meinung zu lässt uns würde man
auch nicht schreiben in den kommentaren
schön dass mal jemand eine andere
meinung hat weil eben auch kein anderer
sich traut mehr das zu sagen und das war
auch das feedback was ich auf meiner
titel bekommen habe was mich außerdem
auch mal stört ist dass ich glaube dass
fielmann im parlament tatsächlich über
das ziel hinaus geschossen ist
nach dem artikel habe ich nachrichten
bekommen von frauen von jungen frauen
die gesagt haben
gut dass das mal jemand schreibt weil
ich fühle mich durch diese bewegung
ja ich wie sage ich in meinen wert
geringer geschätzt weil ich habe mich
entschieden haben einfach eine mutter zu
sein ich möchte zu hause sein ich möchte
den haushalt machen ich möchte noch
hausfrau sein und das ist eine bewusste
entscheidung und ich habe das gefühl ich
bin weniger wert weil es heißt alle
müssen karriere machen und das kann ja
nicht sein dass diese bewegung die vor
jahren mal was gutes angestoßen hat uns
dahin gebracht hat wo wir heute sind
nämlich dass mann und frau
gleichberechtigt sind dass diese
bewegung jetzt ins andere extrem
überschlägt so dass er frauen die das
nicht möchten was völlig in ordnung ist
man kann hausfrau sein und familie haben
dass die sich eingeschüchtert fühlen und
das gefühl sie sind nicht mehr genug
geld für diese gesellschaft das geht
einfach aber am ende des tages sind sie
doch eigentlich dafür für
gleichberechtigung in dem sinne dass
jede frau eigentlich machen können soll
was sie möchte also egal ob es jetzt
karriere machen will oder nicht was ja
viele die für female im parlament wenn
man den begriff jetzt benutzt da
eigentlich auch sind ich habe hier eine
frage von max bei youtube der fragt wie
würden sie die normen und werte
bekämpfen wollen die durch die erziehung
hervorgebracht werden also zum beispiel
wie klar dass klare rollen verständlich
damit wahrscheinlich ein traditionelles
rollenverständnis
also was ich erfahren habe tatsächlich
von der mutter die das sehr aktiv
fördert ist dass sie bewusst ihren
kindern genau die gleichen spielsachen
gegeben hat das ist ja so ein faktor
dass man sagt ja den mädchen kriegen ja
schon immer puppen machen deswegen
vielleicht später ihr pflegejobs jungs
kriegen er das auto vielleicht gehen sie
deshalb in die automobilindustrie
who knows und die das tatsächlich
fördern sie sagt trotzdem greift meine
tochter einfach zu der puppe weil sie
die puppe irgendwie war einfach lieber
mit der stadt und der junge greift er zu
diesem auto und ich kann für mich sagen
ich glaube ich bin in
ja in der familie groß geworden wo meine
eltern das gefördert haben das ja ich
alle optionen haben genauso wie meine
brüder alle optionen haben ich habe
deswegen früh schon fußball gespielt ich
habe tatsächlich auch viel mit jungs
gemacht hab immer mit meinen brüdern auf
der straße gespielt also ich bin auch
und sodann vielleicht ja eher einem
jungs umfeld auch groß geworden und
vielleicht hat mir das auch heute
geholfen irgendwie zu sagen ja ich
brauche keine freunde ich brauch ist
alles nicht macht das einfach so
und ja das ist aber trotzdem interessant
dass selbst wenn man das aktiv fördert
als eltern das irgendwie trotzdem ja
vorlieben einfach gibt und genau so wie
man ja fragen kann ja wieso arbeiten
nicht so viele frauen in technischen
berufen könnte man ja auch mal fragen
warum arbeiten denn eigentlich nicht so
viele männer in pflegeberufen aber das
fragt irgendwie keiner und ragt aber
genau diese vier mal im parlament begebe
bewegung ja nun schon oder gedreht als
nie um die fragen also ich hab noch nie
dass die frage gehört das oder ich
erinner mich nicht ich lasse mich gerne
eines besseren belehren dass es da auch
darum geht ja zu schauen
ja was mit den männern ist es aber
gleichberechtigung ist hat ja nun zwei
seiten das ist ja auch auf jeden total
für männer also da da soll jetzt nicht
jemand unbedingt bevorzugt werden sonst
kann man da und ist endlich jubeln im
parlament warum ist es dann final im
fond mit und das ist ja genau der punkt
also ist es ich glaube durch diese
ständige betonung von diesem female
bewegt sich das irgendwie weg von dem
eigentlichen ziel und vergisst auch
andere perspektiven mit einzubringen
das ist zumindest das was ich erlebe und
auch auf diesen event sehe da geht es
eben immer nur um frauen und was frauen
machen oder nicht machen und tun wir
nicht tun und da geht es eigentlich nie
darum also aus meiner erfahrung was was
mit männern ist warum die eigentlich
gegen pflegeberufen mehr arbeiten also
müsste ich nicht frau villas hier kommt
noch eine frage von eick bei facebook
und zwar oder das ist eher eine aussage
gibt es einfach mal als frage weiter der
sagt alte männer seilschaften müssten
aber doch beendet werden
alte männer bitte seilschaften damit
sind diese männer netzwerke wo man sich
eben zum beispiel gegenseitig fördert
gemeint ja also ich hab das einfach aus
meiner eigenen perspektive und aus den
erzählungen die ich kenne nicht er nie
erlebt dass man bevorzugt wurde weil er
ein mann ist auch nicht eine frau weil
sie eine frau ist sondern
beziehungsweise das eben er noch und das
ist ja auch das stern.de
das sollte ihm so sein dass talente
gefördert werden und nicht männer oder
frauen gefördert werden und ich kann das
nicht so bestätigen ich glaube das ist
längst aufgebrochen in deutschland und
das zeigen eben auch all diese frauen
die mittlerweile ja ob das ein airbus
ist wo eben die frau die technische
entwicklung vorantreibt im vorstand oder
hat das andere posten sind wo frauen
eben diese berufe haben und ja zeigen
dass das nicht mehr diese gesellschaften
geboten der mann sich das gegenseitig so
zu spielen sie sind aber eben doch sehr
vereinzelt wenn wir mal in diese
vorstandsriege guckt dann sitzen da eben
sehr sehr wenige frauen
und deswegen glaube ich auch dass viele
einfach noch einen weiten weg vor sich
sehen bis alle frauen wirklich immerhin
dritte soweit ich weiss also das ist
eine ganze menge und zwei drittel der
frauen in vorständen sind nicht zwei
drittel der vorstände sind nicht frauen
das ist auf jeden fall sicher die seite
ist informierten so albin
aber jetzt mal ganz grundsätzlich noch
mal die frage was spricht denn
eigentlich grundsätzlich dagegen weil
sie haben ja vor allem auch das credo
dass sie sagen frauen werdet
selbstbewusst da frauen werdet mutiger
zeigt auch mal was spricht denn dagegen
die dazu zu animieren und zu sagen traut
euch mehr und gleichzeitig zu sagen na
ja aber eine strukturelle förderung ist
auch in ordnung wenn man zum beispiel an
die grenzen stößt weil es gibt ja nun
frauen die genau diese erfahrung machen
dass sie nicht weiterkommen
also ich glaube das was da vor allem
hilft ist eben nie im parlament es hilft
vor allen dingen eben sich selbst
überlegen wo will ich hin will ich die
steile karriere
dann muss ich im prinzip das in kauf
nehmen muss gucken wie ich dahin komme
muss genauso wie jedermann wie
da habe ich dadurch wachsen und das ist
ein steiniger weg und trotzdem können
frau den frauen den genauso gehen wie
männer
und so sollten wir voranschreiten als
frauen und ich glaube einfach dass wir
die frank wurde dazu einfach nicht
brauchen
das ist die meinung von céline flores
willers vielen dank dass sie sich heute
die zeit für uns genommen haben gerne
dankeschön und ich bedanke mich
natürlich auch bei euch fürs zu sehen
und fürs mitdiskutieren den nächsten
live stream den gibt es hier kommende
woche dann wieder mit daniel mit uns
freuen wenn ihr dann auch wieder dabei
sein
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann gefallen euch
vielleicht auch diese hier klickt euch
doch einfach mal rein oder ihr klickt
hier und lasst einfach ein abo da